Học xin bây giờ lưu học quá, học không có mục tiêu để thấy thành phần tiếp cho các em nhé.
Thì muốn biết là mình thập để làm gì?
Chỉ mình phải có mục tiêu.
Thái tốt học là tôn muốn được chính nghiệm li, mới đi phóng.
Chỉ nghiệm phải là tốt học thì hạ lúc.
Và sau mà em một tiêu tôi làm bác sĩ.
Bí lúc nghĩa hay hả?
Đúng không?
Học là cũng tiêu.
Chua ở tưởng gọi ngồi ngồi ngồi, cũng có học.
Không biết mình cũng tiêu đi.
Chỉ mình phải có không biết một tiêu đi, không biết mình có hành động đi.
Đúng không?
Hành động là để đà được một tiêu mà.
Lòng vì mình cũng cũng tiêu, mình không biết hành động đi nào.
Lúc học cũng không.
Để cho học là ngày trong đặc nó, cũng nhật học người này trong người kia.
Khiều đại này, bác mình thì thay học, kia học.
Khiều đại kia không học người này, kia học.
Hãy ra là chính nghiệm, sợ cũng cũng tiêu.
Gần rất đến là kéo theo của nó đại hệ quả sau này của nó.
Học không tốt, đổi điểm số số, đổi quen kinh thức.
Hãy không nhớ kia thức, bất quan hôm nay, đổi đổi đổi.
Đổi đến từ việc khoảng 10 tiêu.
Hãy giờ khoảng 9 tiêu, đổi đổi đổi đổi đổi đổi.
Hãy tối 1 quá, nó tự này.
Lý được tự này.
Hãy tự này.
Để tạc, hiệm.
Và ở đây học này.
Và sau này đôi 1 là mình ở đây.
Đấy, không có kia phụ của các triệu thế là mà.
Điều bao giờ tự tiêu, thì mình chỉ có chăm.
Học xin năng, ở đây xưa biết biết được được đấy đó.
Hãy giờ đến khi bọng là phói có thể về nhà các bạn.